so a recent article came out with news
week talking about insurance premium in
the State of Florida is up in some
places
900% and you read this articles oh my
God this whole Florida thing maybe it's
a gimmick maybe they're not doing as
good of a job and if you look at the
article it says
275,000 people left the state of Florida
in some places premiums gone from $1,700
to $4,200 per year how are people making
these things happen Farmers massive
company just announced they're leaving
the State of Florida it was so bad that
the CFO ofor Jimmy came out and said
Farmers is the Budweiser anheiser Bush
of the insurance industry because they
follow this ESG score so what is really
going on in Florida are they targeting
the SST are they targeting Florida
because they had the best reputation
during Co and California got destroyed
who knows what I do know is we got all
these slides to go through today on what
the hell is going on in Florida with
insurance okay so if you get value out
of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel but listen to
the people from California you're
watching this video saying oh my gosh
finally Redemption time he's going to
attack Florida and California is going
to come back to being the winner hang
tight listen the reason why I have a
different perspective than some of you
is for the following reason imagine if a
man had dated Marilyn Monroe Elizabeth
Taylor and Sophia Lauren to me all dimes
right he can probably give you a
perspective on all three now I have not
dated those three okay but I have dated
California for 24 years I dated Texas
for 5 years and I'm still dating Florida
for 2 and 1/2 years to kind of give you
some context having said that before you
jump to conclusion whether you're Pro
Florida Pro Texas or Pro California Hank
tight till the end of the video when you
jump to conclusion wait for the data
let's get right into it so stats home
insurance premiums have tripled in the
State of Florida the past 5 years
Florida averages more than $4,200 per
year national average of $1,700 some
insurance premiums have risen by nine
times what they were in 2022 according
to the chief executive of NSI Insurance
Group and construction cost has risen by
40% since 2017 again they give this data
this is Florida this is what's going out
super expensive all right next one
Newsweek I told you earlier Florida
resident flea state has insurance
premiums Skyrocket up to
900% they're not lying this is actually
happening in some places in Florida in
the same article when people are reading
staffs people don't go and investigate
even more they're like oh my god did you
see how many people they said left how
many
275,000 people estimated left Florida
nearly 23,000 people every month and
according to the bureau they relocated a
place like Georgia 46,000 Carolina
42,000 Tennessee 36 South Carolina 31
Texas 30,000 this must be a bad thing A
lot of people are leaving the State of
Florida man we were all talking about
how many people left California where
they were kind of like since 1851 we've
never had this kind of numbers of people
leaving California the whole U-Haul you
know joke that they would say you know
Gavin Nome is the number one U-Haul
salesman because he's got so many people
renting U-Haul to leave the state of
California right so this shows Florida
bad but when you go and look at US
Census Bureau of net positive versus Net
negative guess who is still number one
in that negative in 2022 you ready
California you're not going to like this
okay here you go you ever wonder why
Jamie Diamond CEO of Chase has a $900
million art collection or Steve Cohen
$1.1 billion art collection or Microsoft
has nearly a billion doll collection the
company 5,000 art pieces in 180
different locations worldwide why
because billionaires and millionaires
understand one of the ways to hedge
against inflation money being printed
market crash interest rates is to buy
non duplicatable assets and one of them
is Art Fine Arts and that's why today's
sponsor is Masterworks let me tell you a
little bit about Masterworks you may be
watching the Say pat I'm not a
millionaire or a billionaire I can't
afford to buy a Warhol or a Banky or
basat how am I going to buy that well
Masterworks allows you to buy fractional
shares like buying a share of Apple you
buy a share of a bank SE painting or a
Warhol piece you're able to do that
through Masterworks this is why over
800,000 people have signed up with
Masterworks offerings have sold out
within minutes and many of you have
already created accounts and some of you
that haven't this is your chance to skip
the waiting list and start your
collection today just click on the link
in the description go to
Masterworks once again Masterworks /v or
click on a link below California minus
343,000 people left California according
to Census Bureau New York minus 299,000
people left Illinois minus 141,000
people left but if you go to the net
positive State guess who's at the top
Florida number one domestic net
migration 2022 Florida number one
318,000 see Newsweek you didn't tell the
whole story you know who number two is
Texas
230,000 then it's Carolina then it's
Tennessee then it's Georgia Arizona
Idaho Alabama Oklahoma Nevada you get
the idea at the bottom is California New
York Illinois Jersey Massachusetts blue
blue blue blue blue blue get the idea
what's going on here what people are
doing bad policies have consequences but
they're targeting Florida so let's
continue with the whole Florida concept
seeing what else they're going to tell
us since 2017 11 Property and Casualty
companies that offered homeowners
insurance in Florida liquidated five of
those companies liquidated in 2022
meaning they're they're liquidating
they're no longer wanting to do business
in the State of Florida five of those
companies left in 2022 United Property
and Casualty Insurance Company left in
2023 okay this is obviously not a good
look when you look at the Florida
company's liquidation this is what
you'll find American Capital Insurance
Group uh Avatar Property and Casualty
fednat Florida specialty guarantee
insurance company golf stream Physicians
United plan Southern Fidelity Insurance
St John's United Property Healthcare
universal healthcare Inc Western
Property and Casualty wind Haven
insurance company the list this year you
can find this it's all over the place
not hard to find however several factors
number one they left for high threat of
widespread weather related damage okay
fair Florida's got hurricanes all this
stuff they talk about number two
insurance fraud driven by fraudulent
Roofing claims number three Florida
accounts for 9% of country's home
insurance claims it is home to 79% of
the country's home insurance lawsuits by
the way some of the these can be
addressed by the governor so let's see
what governor Des santis did
underwriting Florida property insurance
are projected to post a cumulative
underwriting loss of $1.7 billion for
2021 due to these Runway litigation
costs according to Mark Freelander
director of corporate Communications at
the insurance information Institute this
is from 2022 and 2023 let's continue
Senate Bill 2D signed by Governor Dan
santis in May of 2022 enacts proc
consumer measures to help alleviate
Rising Insurance costs increases
Insurance claim transparency and cracks
down on frivolous laws that drive up
cost for all Floridians so what does
this mean for a longest time these guys
don't have to report how much it cost
now they're like no no why are you
charging me this much because it is okay
disclose it we need to know there's got
to be transparency he's holding them
accountable so so for some of you that
one more Intel let's go a little bit
deeper and kind of see what governor
DeSantis did so this is what you'll find
here on on flgov.com property insurance
legislation the bills proposed provides
both short and long-term relief for
Floridians that's good provides grant
funding for homeowners to make their
homes more resilient to to storms
resulting in insurance premium discounts
number three reforms the legal
environment to reduce frivolous lawsuits
and last palies cracks down on fraudu
and roofing scams and predatory actors
that's very good by the way this has
happened I've been in life insurance
there was a lot of fraudulent going on
in life insurance and Medicare many
different things this is actually very
normal for states to do so he's taking
the right actions now let's go a little
bit deeper proc consumer measures
provides $2 billion in reinsurance
relief to benefit policy holders over
the next two years dedicates $150
million to the myay Florida home program
which provides grants to Floridian home
homeowners for Hurricane retrofitting
making home safer and other resilient
and more resistant to hurricane damage
results and premium discounts for
homeowners who participate in the
program and requires the Department of
Financial Services to report the average
annual amount of Premium discount for
participating Floridians this perits
insurance companies from denying
coverage based on the age of a roof that
is less than 15 years and strengthens
office of insurance regulation oversight
of insurance companies to better detect
and prevent insolvencies again this is
all good things that he's doing but when
you do this you kind of put putting
insurance companies in corner and
they're kind of saying well it's not as
lenient man I want to kind of leave
because I can make profit other places
that could also happen that's the risk
when you come up with certain
regulations like this so increases
Insurance claim transparencies number
one prohibits insurance companies from
denying claims without communicating
sufficient reason they need that you
know how many times you get rejected can
you tell me why no we don't need to tell
you you need to now tell the client why
you're doing that number two provides
consumer greater access to information
during the claim adjustment process
number three requires Insurance to
provide adjusted reports to policy
holders in a timely manner and last but
not least anti fraud and legal reforms
cracks down on predatory actors who file
fraudulent roof claims reducing
litigation costs which are passed onto
Floridians and limits the assignment of
attorneys fees to contractors and
property insurance cases the
incentivizes frivolous claims and
further stabilizing premiums what does
this do those who are doing these things
those actors are going to say I'm no
longer going to do business in Florida
and I'm going to leave and it's going to
actually increase the quality of
business that people are doing and the
actors that are trying to take advantage
they leave so so now somebody may say
but Pat you know this is great you know
you could lose a customer here and there
on some of those insurance companies you
read we've never heard of those
companies but everybody knows Farmers
isn't Farmers like massive you're right
Farmers is massive so what does farmers
do Farmers Insurance has become the
latest insurance company to pull out of
Florida they said the move will affect
only company branded policies which
account for about 30% of policy sold in
the state fourth major insur to leave
the Florida Market in the past year with
most citing the risk from hurricanes so
what are some of the big insurance
companies that I've left Florida here
you go you got Farmers Lexington
Centurion Bankers have left Florida so
now if you're thinking like me you're
asking a question is it just Florida
that farmers left or are there other
states they don't do business with and
is there a pattern with these states
like what did they do here's a list of
states that farmers doesn't do business
with Alaska where is it at Coast
Delaware Coast Hawaii Coast Maine Coast
New Hampshire Rhode Island Vermont West
Virginia all of these places are in a
place where they have a higher chance of
getting some risk and by the way even in
the state of California they kind of
have a Crea a way where they don't
necessarily do with everybody but
they're a little bit tighter and
stricter on who they underwrite so now
the questions I want to know is is this
happening across the board and America
or is it just a Florida thing what
states are premiums increasing more than
others and what states is lower here's a
list for you okay so if you look at the
largest increase Florida is at the top
35% that number is a real number then
it's Idaho Colorado South Dakota
Oklahoma Texas Louisiana Arizona
Nebraska you see the list of names some
people may say it's only the red states
that are increasing how about the blue
States go to Blue states smallest
increase Vermont we know who's from
there the legendary Bernie Sanders New
York we know where New York leans
California Nevada Maine New Hampshire
Wisconsin they had a smaller increase so
why is that some states like I've been
in the life insurance industry for 20
plus years you ever heard of New York
Life youve heard of New York Life you
know what's one of the worst businesses
to do insurance in New York and New York
Life is from New York how weird is that
that's one of the hardest states to do
insurance with why overly regulated so
you have to balance over regulation cuz
then people don't want to do business
there and you have to also balance under
regulation where insurance companies can
kind of just come and say nope you got
to pay for this and we don't have to
explain it Florida has to kind of figure
out where they stand with this ranking
here so one argument some people are
making are saying well listen this is
all because Governor Des Sanz took such
hard lines when it comes on to ESG and
it's one of the biggest anti-g states
and when you look at this map here based
on Bloomberg you'll see this red are the
anti-g states with the most loss against
them then you have those who boycott the
law those who are both anti-g and
boycott then you got the the divestment
and a pro ESG law if you notice Florida
on the bottom right is anti-g and
Farmers is one of those companies that
is fully committed to making sure they
have a high ESG score so one would say
well those stories kind of go together
and maybe behind closed doors somebody
influenced Farmers to leave Florida
because you know Florida is not really
an ESG ESG state that could be something
to consider so I want you to see this
exchange of different thoughts from the
CFO of Florida Jimmy he continues but I
also want you to hear what the CEO of
farmers have to say watch this so Jimmy
says while they're bad at helping people
this is Farmers is what he's saying
they're good at virtual signaling
instead of focusing on their policy
holders and running a functioning
business to ensure became the first
us-based insurer to become signatory of
the United Nations principles for
sustainable Insurance very interesting
okay first to do that now watch this
here's a response from the CEO of
farmers and see if there's anything
about ESG there this is him Farmers is
committed to operating in a way that
positively impacts our customers our
employees and communities by
incorporating environmental social in
governance ESG considerations into our
business so maybe the CFO uh Florida was
right on what Farmers is focused on
we'll see now let's see if uh you know
the CFO Jimmy petronis knows what he's
talking about maybe he's just kind of
upset at what they did let's actually go
to the UN website and see if we can find
Farmers here's what we found un
influence last signatory stats 151
signatories 103 supporting institutions
if we look further the UN influence
convened by Geneva Switzerland Bay
Secretariat more than 500 Banks and
insurance with assets exceeding ready
$170
trillion that's a lot of influence
working together to facilitate the
implementation of unep fi principles for
responsible Banking and principles for
sustainable insurance as well as the
three un convene Net Zero alliances
we'll talk about that in a second now to
learn more about unep fi this
organization founded in 1992 was the
first organization to engage with
Finance sector on sustainability and
incubator the principles for responsible
investment now the world's leading
proponent of responsible investment
today we cultivate leadership and
advanced sustainable Market practice
while supporting the implementation of
global programs at a regional level
across Africa Middle East Asia Pacific
Europe Latin America Caribbean and North
America principles for sustainable
Insurance PSI established in 2012 by
unep and today applied by one quarter of
the world's insures 25% of world premium
PRI established in 2006 by United
Nations and the UN Global impact and
applied by half the world's
institutional investors again $83
trillion by 2022 that's a lot of assets
it's a lot of money and and and by the
way the three Finance sectors that they
were talking about for the Net Zero
Alliance the first one is net zero asset
owner Alliance AOA launched in 2019 with
a membership of more than 70
institutional assets with over $10
trillion in assets about 7% of global
investment number two Net Zero banking
Alliance and zba launched in 2021 with
over 100 Banks and US $65 trillion in
assets about half of the global banking
industry assets and last but not least
Net Zero Insurance Alliance nzia
launched in 2021 convening 25 leading
Insurance representing about 12% of
world premium and and by the way guess
who's on that list un influence Bingo
when you look at this Farmers Insurance
who knows maybe Farmers left because
they're being pressured by un ESG Dei
who knows but there's some influence
there when a state like Florida and
Governor Ronda Santa says I don't
support you bullying your ESG policies
in my state with un and he makes all
that noise there's a lot of quiet people
that nobody knows their names or their
faces behind closers going to work to
say I don't like this guy we have to
make their life hard guess what let's
EXP expose him let's write a bunch of
things about the State of Florida and
hurt his reputation when he's running
for president is that true is it not
happening I don't know but it's worth
speculating that there's a possibility
of that happening so so if you're
watching and saying Pat I don't even
know about the war with him again ESG
are we just making this up I've not been
following the story what's the Santa
said about ESG well let's take a deeper
dive and kind of see what he said about
ESG August 2022 Governor Ronda santis
along with fellow Trustees of the State
Board of administration SBA passed a
resolution directing the state of
Florida's manager to invest State funds
in a manner that prioritizes the highest
return on investment for Florida's
taxpayers and retirees without
considering the ideological agenda of
the environmental social and corporate
governance movement ESG Florida pulled
$2 billion from Black Rock Venture funds
back in December 2022 you think Larry
fin likes that he doesn't like that you
pulled how dare you do you know
everybody says yes to me who do you
think you are to say you're going to
pull $2 billion you Governor DeSantis
you I'm not not saying Larry said that
but maybe something like that went
through his mind Florida's Chief
Financial Officer said his Department
would pull $2 billion worth of its asset
managed by Black Rock the biggest such
divestment by a state again biggest such
divestment by a state opposed the asset
managers environmental social and
governance policies the move will hardly
Dent anything with black rock this
company's a to10 trillion doll of assets
under management they don't really care
about that what they do care about is an
article that says a state had the brass
to stand up against black
what because if you do that maybe you're
going to teach other states to follow
Governor DeSantis that's not good for
them by the way if you want to read
further you can we'll put the link below
but I want to read one of them here some
things that he's prohibiting prohibiting
the financial sector from considering
so-called social credit scores there's a
lot of people that are worried about the
social credit scores because they're
doing that in a lot of different places
in banking and lending practices that
aim to prevent Floridians from up
obtaining lines of credit and bank
accounts can you imagine if somebody
says I don't like what you posted the
other day nope we're not going to give
him this loan Florida's trying to
protect that from becoming the norm
that's become in many different places
they had it in Europe you had the you
know vaccine passport you were traveling
at the airports can you imagine like
they don't want to bring that to the
State of Florida so if you're against
this guess what you support what Ronda
santis is fighting against but if you
say I want a social credit score then
Florida's not the state for you I I want
to go a little bit deeper with this
whole concept some of you guys may be
asking a very valid question why why
would farmers be afraid of Black Rock
who the hell is black Black Rock
wouldn't you want to have a better
relationship with Florida than a black
rock well you have to understand that
when it comes on to Black Rock they
don't just give institutional money they
also lend to big companies so imagine if
you're worth 8 to 10 trillion dollar of
assets some of that money you're lending
to people and you're getting interest
back so when you're borrowing money from
a company like black rock you don't want
them to charge you 8% you want them to
charge you the least possible because
you are in good standing with them but
Black Rock if your score isn't good they
can say Farmers you didn't do right with
us in the State of Florida instead of
giving this thing to you at 4% we're
going to give it to you at 8% 7% 9% that
may not seem like a lot of money that's
a lot of money and by the way when you
look at this chart here here's what
you'll notice okay Market size for
broadly syndicated loans in America is
$1.2 trillion Europe is $200 billion and
private Direct Loans Market US market is
910 billion and in Europe is
$120 billion this is why companies like
Farmers want to be on the good graces of
a place like Black Rock they worry if we
don't do right by them they're not going
to lend us more money does that kind of
make sense if you want to of unpacking
and you're like Pat I want to know what
part of that $1.2 trillion goes to
different industry how much of it is
insurance for Farmers to be afraid of it
let's take a look at this chart this is
the US broadly syndicated loan Market
breakdown and if you look at this the
dark blue is the Clos okay these are
collateralized loan obligations but if
you go to Insurance that's PNC and life
PNC stands for Property and Casualty and
life light blue baby blue all the way at
the top there to the right you'll notice
2% the 100% is 1.2 trillion but 2% still
equates to $24 billion it's a lot a lot
of money that companies like Farmers one
of the biggest companies they need
access to that $24 billion so it's real
money we're talking about here so let me
give you my final thoughts on this year
number one we learned during coid one
very simple thing maybe more than ever
before that Governors matter Governor
Des santis had better policies than
Governor Nome okay one got people to
show up here the other one lost people
what is the problem of losing people you
got to replace them but what is the
problem of gaining a lot of people holy
prices are going to go up you know
cost of living is going to go up
everything's going to go up how are we
going to handle all this stuff they both
have a problem it's a different problem
when a company is growing very very fast
you don't have money to catch up with
the growth that's still a problem when a
company is not growing you're also
losing money both is a different problem
to solve nome's got to make sure he
makes an argument for people say come to
California no one's coming he's got to
make a better place to say listen those
of you guys that came to Florida you got
to stay here so regulation you know some
may say well we need to deregulate and
some say we need to over regulate
California is over regulated New York is
over-regulated Illinois is over
regulated Florida is here so as a parent
have two sons if I don't have proper
regulation in my house my oldest son
could bully my youngest son employer I'm
an employer we have employees I need to
be held accountable to certain levels my
employees need to be held to certain
levels okay if one is over the other the
other one doesn't have an incentive to
do something so Governor Des santis has
to figure out the balance of Regulation
so these insurance companies don't just
charge premium because they can and
these other people don't go abuse and
and take advantage of insurance
companies with fraud cuz they can't so
he's dealing with that part but more
than anything else the ESG story tells
you it's real that is involved they have
a lot of influence it is becoming deeply
concerning to a lot of different people
and there's a big part of America that
doesn't want to live in a place that
companies like Black Rock have such a
big influence over what they get to do
small business owners don't want to be
controlled by companies like Black Rock
they want to be able to say look I got
access to you but I don't want you to
give me access because of a way I Vote
or because I took the vaccine or because
I did this or I didn't do that just
Judge Me based on the kind of a business
I buil not who's Middle Eastern not
who's black not who's white not who's
women all this that's just nonsense let
me build a good business if we have a
good profitable environment our
employees are happy we take care of the
people in our community reward us for it
nothing more nothing less if we don't do
it we'll go out of business so there's a
reason why Ronda Sanz is running for
office because many of his policies
attracted a lot of people here and now
he's probably being targeted and he's
got to show his fight it's not easy not
everybody wants to be a governor he
chose to be a governor not an easy job
but I trust he's going to do his fight
and show up like he has the last few
years having said that if you've not
seen the video by the way if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel but if
you've not seen the video we did on ESG
it's a mustat by the way if you've not
seen the one on Larry think click here
but if you've not seen the one on ESG
click here both of them are great videos
take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye